today let's talk about two really
important things to prevent premature
graying of your hair now if you look at
my hair at the top okay
all this is natural of course you can
see
let's see on this side a little gray
right here a little gray right here
there is a factor of age and eventually
everyone will have gray hair but the
whole goal of this video is to show you
how to prevent the prematuring of this
graying of your hair so many people are
getting gray hair just way too early
it's not all genetics
genetics do play a part but there's also
something called epigenetics which are
things that you can do which are above
your genes so even though you might have
genes that give you a propensity to get
gray hair there's a lot of things that
you can do about it but there's two
really important things you need to know
one is the actual pigment in the hair
that gives you the coloring and the
enzymes to allow that pigment to occur
are dependent on a trace mineral called
copper if you are deficient in Copper
you might have a tendency to get gray
hair prematurely but why are people
deficient in Copper
yes it could be coming from your diet
because you're not consuming High copper
foods which I will talk about shortly
but there's another thing that you need
to know high levels of cortisol as in
stress
complete copper because cortisol uses a
lot of copper enzymes
so in other words more stress equals
more demand for copper equals more loss
of copper and when you run out of copper
and you don't have enough enzyme that
enzyme is called tyrosinase to make this
melanin to keep your natural color in
your hair things start to go gray so how
does this apply to you
well stress you've probably even
experienced The more stress that you
have the more gray hairs you might find
in your head so of course the solution
is to
do whatever you can to reduce stress but
in the meantime as you're doing that
there's other things you can do to
increase copper like eat more Foods
higher in Copper I don't necessarily
recommend taking a copper supplement by
itself I recommend that you try to get
it from the foods however you could take
a copper supplement but you have to make
sure that it also has other trace
minerals especially zinc in there
because zinc and copper work together
you never want to just take like a
standalone Trace mineral with copper and
the ratios need to be correct too you
usually need like a 1 to 10 ratio one
copper to 10 zinc so in other words you
don't want to take a lot of copper you
just want to take sufficient amounts now
before we get into the foods for that
let me just explain this other thing
that's equally as important and that is
basically age the aging process what
happens when you age you get this
accumulation of hydrogen peroxide that
builds up in the hair shaft okay and
hydrogen peroxide causes like a
bleaching effect of your hair so the
other question is okay how do you slow
down the aging process well you'd want
to slow down the accumulation of
hydrogen peroxide to it at the very
least keep the color in your hair
there is an enzyme that naturally breaks
down hydrogen peroxide very quickly
actually it's called catalase but before
you go out and buy another supplement
with catalase I don't recommend that I
recommend eating foods high in catalase
which I'll explain in a minute but let
me just first explain a little bit more
about catalytics because it's very
interesting catalase breaks hydrogen
peroxide down into water in oxygen like
one molecule of catalase
can break down a million molecules of
hydrogen peroxide in less than a second
so by having enough catalase in your
body you can slow down this hydrogen
peroxide phenomena that occurs with
aging and as one side note your immune
system okay uses hydrogen peroxide like
the white blood cells use hydrogen
peroxide as a weapon against pathogens
so if you have this low-grade infection
or you know a lot of times people have
chronic fatigue syndrome they have this
like Epstein-Barr virus or some type of
herpes virus that kind of keeps coming
out of remission in remission that type
of thing that can be releasing a lot of
hydrogen peroxide so having a healthy
immune system is really important so
number one we need to lower our stress
as well as increase the copper to build
the enzyme to keep the pigment in your
hair okay and then over here we need to
increase catalytes to keep this hydrogen
peroxide as low as possible so what are
the foods that are highest in copper
all of the Seafoods shellfish especially
oysters are very important and secondly
mushrooms eating more mushrooms have
that copper-based enzyme tyrosinics and
by the way you can also get copper in
organic grass-fed beef liver and if
you're vegan you can also get it from
spirulina so that's those Foods now what
about foods that can increase head lace
you can get catalase from grass-fed beef
liver vegetables especially cruciferous
vegetables and Sprouts or micro greens
are loaded with catalase so when you
have your salad each day make sure you
add some microgreens or some Sprouts
that way you can get a little bit more
catalase and of course if you're having
a salad you know maybe you do arugula as
your base because that's a cruciferous
and then you can also saute but not
overcook other cruciferous vegetables
and of course on top of all that you
want to work on your stress you want to
do things exercise to release stress you
want to also maintain a stress-free
attitude about life and that could too
serious and stuck in stress you want to
avoid smoking alcohol junk Foods sugars
refined carbs and one more point about
catalase
I found one study that showed that you
don't want to go low-fat a higher fat
diet can help increase catalase as in
the ketogenic diet so we keep coming
back to this healthy version of the
ketogenic diet that I keep recommending
where you're doing nutrient dense foods
where you're doing cruciferous
vegetables where you're doing grass-fed
meats and even organ meats and if you
don't like organ meats you can always
get those in the supplement and one last
a real interesting point about catalase
I found another research study on mice
okay so if you have any pet mice this
could apply that found when they
stimulated the the gene for catalase
they there was a significant increase in
lifespan which is interesting which
would make sense because catalase works
on your mitochondria and it's an
antioxidant and too much hydrogen
peroxide can create a lot of free
radical damage and destroy the
mitochondria so now that we covered the
premature grain of the hair let's talk
about the hair in general is there other
things that can make your hair healthier
and the answer is yes in this video you
can find out